welcome back to my series of spider-man
reviews we've covered the Raimi trilogy
and now we're moving into Marc Webb's
trilogy Oh actually it's just two movies
awkward the amazing spider-man a lot of
people were excited about this movie it
was being marketed as the untold story
of the beloved webslinger which was a
clever ploy to get us to sit in the
theater expecting something new and to
give us a reason for this reboot
actually existing Marc Webb directed
this movie he was plucked from indie
obscurity after making the very good 500
days of summer and he made a movie with
no style of his own really in truth this
film comes off as a 2 hour and 16 minute
indie rock music video featuring someone
who resembles spider-man hate me yet
good cuz I'm not done so look i
rewatched this movie yesterday because i
haven't really enjoyed this movie since
it came out and a lot of people have
told me that they feel that I'm
incorrect or I'm being too harsh on the
movie so I rewatched this movie last
night and I studied it I mean I studied
it frame for frame I took like 10 pages
of notes I am prepared to discuss why I
don't personally enjoy the amazing
spider-man it'd be easy for me to sit
here and say oh I don't like this movie
it sucks it's dumb and not really give
you any concrete reasons but that's not
what I'm gonna do let's get in-depth
about the amazing spider-man spoiler
filled of course here's the reasons why
this movie disappointed me let's talk
about Peter Parker obviously he's the
most well-rounded character in this
movie you learn a little bit about his
parents but really not that much you
care about him kind of but in the long
run I just didn't like Andrew Garfield's
portrayal of Peter Parker he's kind of a
punk
he likes to skateboard in the halls when
teachers tell him not to he humiliates
Flash on purpose he's kind of a creeper
as well taking pictures of Gwen Stacy
from a distance I didn't feel much
sympathy for him in this movie which was
a major letdown for me and Andrew
Garfield as I watched this movie kind of
portrays Peter as if he has a hangover
in almost every scene
let's talk about the good and bad of
spider-man's character development the
good is that he's a little bit more
quippy for one Scene one of the major
complaints with Raimi spider-man trilogy
was that Spiderman wasn't quippy enough
he didn't make enough jokes so they
heard you and they made one scene for
you in which he demolishes this car
thief he sprays webbing all over him
even on the nutsack he calls him names
he makes fun of the cop even as well now
that was one scene for the fans
please look at that from a filmmaking
perspective that really was just one
scene they said okay we'll get the scene
out of the way where he makes jokes and
then they never have him do it again it
was just a fanservice scene for us at
least in the Raimi films the quips well
minimal or spread out here they just did
one quick scene in which the only goal
of that scene was to make spider-man
tell some jokes and move on from there
and never have him do it again I do
however think Andrew Garfield is far
more likable as spider-man than he is as
Peter Parker he definitely understands
the character and what I like about his
portrayal is that in real life he really
is a humongous fan of spider-man and it
was special to him and you can tell that
he's really trying to honor it I
personally don't care if he has organic
web shooters or he makes the web
shooters himself let's get this out of
the way I hate the suit in this movie it
looks like a basketball and trust me
I've heard every single defense for that
well he's just a poor high schooler how
can he afford to make a really awesome
suit like some Hollywood costume
designer well if he's so poor how can he
afford to make web shooters with tencel
string that can balance a human being
between skyscrapers or attach multiple
cars to a bridge if he can create that
tech he should be able to make a suit
that looks better than a basketball
let's talk about the character
development of Gwen Stacy uh there is
none I like Emma Stone quite a bit she's
a very likable actress and she gets a
lot of laughs in this movie because she
is funny as a person and you can feel
that seeping through her there's good
chemistry there between Peter and Gwen
these actors were dating in real life so
that probably helped but we watching
this movie I found no attempt to develop
her character even in the slightest here
are her two character traits she has a
crush on Peter Parker and she can make
an antidote for lizard serum in like
five minutes the most impactful thing
that happens
her character happens at the end of the
movie when her father dies and that's
the end of the movie
how about Aunt May and Uncle Ben well
Aunt May's role in this movie is to
worry Peter comes home Aunt May's
worried Peter comes home Aunt May's
worried it happens about five times she
doesn't really do much in the film
except worry over and over again Martin
Sheen is Uncle Ben does a fairly good
job he's good in this movie it's just
that the film has such a hard time
balancing the brilliant performance that
Cliff Robertson gave in the first one
the with great power comes great
responsibility line and trying not to
copy too much off Raimi's films and so
they throw in this if you could do good
things for other people you had a moral
obligation to do those things that's
what's at stake here not choice
responsibility it's like they were
afraid to just say it again for some
reason and they had to figure out a
different way to write the exact same
phrase and it just comes off so tired
here's the big one for me in regards to
character development dr. Connors
slashed the lizard is without a doubt
the worst developed worst fleshed out of
any of the spider-man villains in the
four films we had received at that time
what's the motivation for his character
while he's trying to work on
cross-species genetics he's trying to
regrow his arm and he has a deadline
because Norman Osborn the head of Oscorp
is dying we never see this man we never
meet Norman Osborn but we're supposed to
somehow care about this character we've
never seen the urgency of dr. Connors
situation is entirely because Irfan Khan
comes in every once in a while and says
hey Norman Osborn is dying you need to
create this and you need to do it fast
and for some reason we're supposed to
care about his situation the real
motivation though is regrowing his arm
so he eventually injects himself and
becomes the first human trial the
problem is the entire development of his
character rests around him wanting to
regrow his arm which leads into him
transforming into a monster all
development given to his character is so
that he could become this lizard
creature once that happens the script
has no idea what to do with this man and
he just becomes insane and starts
getting voices in his head like Norman
Osborn in the first spider-man film and
for some reason can Cox the most idiotic
plan a villain could ever have turned
all of New York into
creatures where did this come from it's
the worst writing for a spider-man
villain in any of the films thus far
there was an overabundance of villains
in spider-man 3 but at least their
motivation was clear I understood why
Harry hated Peter I understood why Eddie
hated Peter I understood why Sandman
wanted to provide for his daughter in
this film the motivation for the lizards
insanely idiotic plan is so unclear
there were however a lot of deleted
scenes where dr. Connors had a son and
there was something wrong there and it
was like hey there's something oh they
removed it from the movie now there's
nothing now that I've talked about the
poor character development let's talk
about the filmmaking the directing the
storytelling this is a dull drab looking
movie with an emphasis on dark grey
colors which is such an odd choice for a
character as colorful as spider-man the
action sequences are largely flat and
sometimes rapidly edited like the subway
sequence where Peter first discovers his
powers it takes 94 minutes to get to the
first real confrontation between the
lizard and spider-man and I'm talking
about a sequence what's a sequence well
that would be like the Time Square scene
in the first spider-man or the train
scene in spider-man 2 those are
sequences Spidey in the lizard in a
sewer where the lizard scratches him on
the chest and then spider-man falls into
a pipe that's not a sequence that's like
a little moment this school
confrontation is 94 minutes into this
movie where we finally get something of
meat between these two characters before
that the film is bogged down by heavy
montage sequences including three Bing
Search Results scenes three let's talk
about exposition this film is riddled
with it there are so many scenes where
characters need to be progressed from
point A to point B and the writers have
no idea how to do this except let's have
Peter go to Curt Connors house and Curt
will tell him a whole bunch of stuff
about his parents I guess the worst
defense of this by far is when Peter
finds the lizard's lair in the sewer and
there is literally a gigantic pile of
exposition just waiting for him
including videos that he can press play
on and hear the lizard's entire plan
spoken to him it's very offensive to me
that this is how the screenwriters chose
to tell this story just have Peter
stumble across information throughout
the entire film let's talk about
disappearing characters and/or subplots
Peter completely abandons the search for
his uncle's killer after like a
10-minute montage sequence and it's
never brought up again ever
he looks everywhere for this guy he
beats up all these thugs and nothing
comes of it it's like the writers were
just looking for little subplots to fill
up the script and when they got bored of
one of them they just abandoned it and
moved on to something else that's how
this film feels let's talk about Irfan
Khan this is a terrific actor very
famous in India and if you go and read
the IMDB user reviews for when this
movie first came out and specifically
look for usernames that look as if
they're an Indian name most of these
reviews are like where did Irfan Khan go
where this guy he's like the Tom Cruise
of India this guy is very famous and
he's an excellent actor it's disgraceful
in so many ways that his character
vanishes from this movie there was a
deleted scene where his character
appeared at the bottom of the sewer and
gave some finality and closure to his
character but it was deleted it's not in
the movie so I can't act like it was
he's on the bridge and they never talk
about him again he just vanishes into
thin air let's talk about some of the
stylistic choices there really aren't
much mostly this film comes off as I
said like an indie rock music video
there are so many sequences that are
just montages filled with songs that can
fill up the soundtrack there really
isn't that much style to this movie you
can't really differentiate this film as
anyone director with Sam Raimi's trilogy
those felt like Sam Raimi movies like
the hospital scene in spider-man 2
nothing about Marc Webb's film feels
like a Marc Webb film it all feels very
workman like let's talk about the ending
the crane swinging sequence is cool
because spider-man looks awesome
swinging around and we all love to see
spider-man swinging around on buildings
but what's really happening there
nothing of impact is happening here
there is one construction worker that
starts this in motion who's spider-man
helped earlier by saving his son on that
bridge but besides that the reason this
sequence has no
pacta me is because you're finally
seeing the city support spider-man is
supposed to be like oh my gosh they're
supporting him yes but there's never a
scene in this movie where the city
doesn't support spider-man there's never
a sequence where the city is depicted as
hating spider-man in fact the only
character that is depicted as not
supporting spider-man is Captain Stacy
played by Denis Leary which is why when
captain Stacy and spider-man team up to
defeat the lizard at the end that felt
like it had some emotional weight
because there was an arc there I don't
care about the city helping spider-man
with cranes because the city has never
been a character of itself that hated or
disliked spider-man everyone was always
in support of him
to be honest throughout this entire
sequence I was more curious what was
happening to those cops that the lizard
sprayed with the gas that were turning
into lizard cops for like 15 minutes I
want to know what happened during those
15 minutes I want to see a spin-off
short film called lizard cops about the
15 minutes where the lizard cops were
lizard creatures what was happening on
the ground this film is a mess I'm sorry
this films a mess
well spider-man is fighting the lizard
there are lizard cops running around in
New York I guess and it never goes back
to that it's just so Gwen within like
eight minutes creates an antidote for
this thing and it really is like they
had no idea how to end this movie it's
honestly like the writers were sitting
there and just they were like I we don't
know what to do just make the lizard
shoot gas everywhere it turns everyone
into creatures who cares why he wants to
do it have Gwen make an antidote who
cares how she knows how to make this
antidote just who freakin cares it's
spider-man
we're Sony okay they'll go and pay to
see it alright just write whatever so
Captain Stacy's dying wish is that Peter
stay away from Gwen in the comics
captain Stacy actually wanted Peter to
protect Gwen captain Stacy was on the
side of Peter in the comics he switched
that around for this movie
Parker promises this and then like five
minutes later changes his mind
the end
guys I would honestly rather watch
spider-man three over this movie any day
you want to know why that movie's a mess
I don't like that movie but at least
it's characters motivations are clear
and most of the characters do have
development that are given to them even
though there's an overabundance of
stories and it's very messy at least all
the characters do feel like characters
this film feels heavily like a product
to me they tried to reboot spider-man by
catering to fans who didn't like Sam
Raimi's films by saying this was going
to be an untold story with things like
web shooters and quips and made it seem
like it was going to be this very
special film and to me it's a gigantic
mess I'm gonna give the amazing
spider-man a c-minus guys those are my
thoughts in the amazing spider-man I'm
going to have my review of the amazing
spider-man 2 very soon for you guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes